what do 75.9 million people in America
have in common well they love a good
podcast and Silas reports that there's a
good reason they might all be getting a
psychological Boost from popping on a
pod now a new city says that they help
fulfill our need for social engagement
and if you have podcast hosts that you
love and you might be feeling connected
to them that gives you a greater sense
of relatedness Ross do you have a
favorite podcast I mean guess is it
yours no it's not my podcast Hello Ross
plugged no I I do listen to podcasts
though because I take the train into the
City and I walk here every day and I I
you know in my life is I talk about pop
culture and dating and fun and all the
things I'm into we love but I also love
politics so I find myself listening to
these political podcasts hardcore left
hardcore right I just love people that
are passionate about it and it's funny
I'm walking beep up down the street and
there's like Keith olberman screaming in
my ear or something